just a reminder I have been doing
sporadic Facebook live streams and I
hope you will join me on Facebook live I
take questions i'll talk about stories
we didn't get to on the show I'll
preview upcoming shows it's all
happening on Facebook live facebook.com
slash david packard show quick update on
the indiegogo crowdfunding campaign we
are attempting to raise sixty thousand
dollars by midnight on the day of
President Donald Trump's inauguration
you can read about the campaign and
donated david pakman.com slash donate we
are up very quickly approaching the ten
thousand dollar mark moving the campaign
into five digits we have also passed the
250 donor mark over 250 individual
donors having donated at this point we
have all sorts of great perks available
the perks start at just nine dollar
donations the most popular perks so far
as david pakman show bumper stickers
although i but viewers have confirmed
that my suspicions are right many of
those bumper stickers will be going not
on to actual car bumpers but on two
laptops backpacks and refrigerators and
that's all great it's called the bumper
sticker but with peace and love you put
it wherever you want the most popular
perk so far the bumper sticker second
most popular perk is the autographed
2017 david pakman show calendar I've not
mentioned the calendar for a little bit
and you can check it out at david
pakman.com slash donate this is a 20-17
calendar with all original artwork
artwork created by david pakman show fan
dan burke who is just an awesome artist
it's sort of comic book colouring book
themed and you will see not only me but
so many of your favorite and most hated
politicians i guess we could say in the
artwork that's the second most popular
perk so far through the campaign third
most popular perk is the david pakman
show logo t-shirt followed by the david
pakman show logo hoodie sweatshirt but
we've recently added a custom exclusive
hatred mail shirt as a perk for the
indiegogo campaign and that is very very
quickly surging in the ranks i would
assume that the hate
at mail shirt and the established in
2005 shirt will soon make it uh into the
top perks even if it you can only donate
a dollar to please do it every donation
makes a difference we are looking to
hire a progressive engagement
coordinator to organize and coordinate
progressive actions on issues and
candidates that matter we are looking to
also uh have that coordinator work with
or organize multiple independent
progressive shows to coordinate activism
and really increase the impact of our
efforts now that the official Electoral
College voting has been done it's going
to be President Donald and we need to be
united and coordinated we're also going
to be making some upgrades the david
pakman show studio i'm not missing from
the studio today because the studio has
fallen apart or anything like that i am
broadcasting remotely cuz i've got some
family business out in western
Massachusetts but needless to say we
have some major plans as part of the
fundraiser for the david pakman show
studio and a lot of other great stuff
including getting the show on amazon
prime so please donations of all amounts
welcome whether it's one dollar or
whether it's 499 dollars which is
currently the top donation that we've
seen from a longtime viewer named joshua
or whether it's more than 499 raising
the bar on the biggest donation every
single donation is much appreciated and
last thing on this and then i'll move on
uh anybody who makes a donation of any
amount to the campaign will qualify for
a half price David Pakman show
membership after you donate within 24 to
48 hours you'll get an email with a
special code offering you the
opportunity to get a membership at half
price and that even a dollar donation
will qualify you for that